wie ich hier okay das ganze kiste wenn
ich hier ein cook habe ich irgendwie
hier noch sonst lot ich weiß nicht woher
kommt falle ich meine lieben freunde und
herzlich willkommen zu einer weiteren
folge der micro effects heute am
dienstagabend weil ich gerade einfach
mal in jedem start gegangen um mir ein
toaster gekauft habe und ganz viel lohn
thailand ganz viel toastbrot weil die
bock auf toastbrot ich habe wieder 56
rausgesucht eigentlich habe ich diesmal
sogar 66 rausgesucht weil einige meinten
höhe da war letztens folge 64 und ein
minecraft stack an 64 blöcke es heißt du
mussten special machen bei den fake sich
ab jetzt einfach nicht weiß nicht ich
mag special nicht so gern deswegen aber
jetzt einfach einen effekt mehr drin ich
hoffe euch passt sondern würde ich sagen
fangen direkt an mit dem ersten vers
meine fähigkeiten aber kurzzeitig so als
euch eigentlich fragt warum ich in
diesem komischen kopf habe das ist mir
auch gerade erst aufgefallen und zwar
habe ich mir irgendwie den kopf von
konkreter aufgesetzt aber irgendwie ist
das eigentlich kann ich meinen kopf also
gar keine ahnung also mit vor sich geht
aber wir kommen jetzt die mal zum ersten
tag der bis zu gesendet wurde von conny
ich habe neulich einen mein kraftwerk
herausgefunden weiß aber nicht ob du ihn
schon einmal erzählt hast wenn man im
creative mode sich das wetterportal
fliegt geht sprintet et cetera kommt man
immer sofort in den abwertenden notiert
man allerdings im survival mode im durch
dauert es kurz also es kommt immer
dieser ladebildschirm in lila ich den
man sehe ich das mal ganz kurz ich bin
im creative mord ihr seht das ja ich
kann hier umfliegen und fliege jetzt
beispielsweise portal und ihr seht schon
zack landschaft wieder runter geladen
ich bin direkt immer wenn ich jetzt die
ganze mal kommen lassen mag aber zum
glück sind wir im creative mord und
direkt mal ein portal und das pferd ist
im weg und ich kann das portal nicht
anzünden
frag mich nicht wie dieses fertig
hingekommen ist das ist in irgendwelchen
tests passiert und jetzt ist das hat
aber auch schon einfach weg gut ihr seht
hier ist das portal und auch wenn ich
rein laufe ich bin einfach direkt in der
nächsten welt drin wenn ich jetzt
allerdings mal allen gebe game mode 0
dann kann ich ganz einfach mal hier rein
springen dann kommt erst dieser
bildschirm und erlebte ein bisschen und
dann komme ich erst in den elfer die
ladezeit ist die gleiche allerdings ist
das denke ich dafür gemacht dass wenn
man irgendwie im survival mode kurz mal
aussehen da kann man mal durchs portal
laufen und so im great if not ist es so
als wenn man eventuell den netter meidet
dann kann man halt noch mal wenn man
drin ist eventuell sich denken
wenn ich geh doch mal raus und im
creative mord ist das scheißegal oder
halt ganz einfach dass wenn man hier von
leuten verfolgt dass man nicht einfach
das portal gehen kann es direkt woanders
sondern dass man auch kurz diesen
herzstillstand moment doch noch
irgendwie anders man so hilfe ich welt
verfolgt von garz und guckt sich dann so
um so an
bitte hilf und dann wird jetzt zum
beispiel das portal aus geschossen ist
natürlich worst case ich weiß nicht
genau woran es liegt eventuell weise
einer von euch
kia hat mit dem feld zugesendet also
nicht kia sowie das auto kia sondern und
der nächste feld wurde mir zugesendet
von loßburg sparks lp und zwar schreibt
der bellen im singleplayer auf escape
druck wird alles gestoppt außer eine
sache das testmatch mal eben ganz klein
geschrieben welche sache das ist ich
zeige euch das erst mal ganz gut so zwar
irgendwie ist es zieht auch wieder recht
cool also diese landzungen hier war
nicht so die habe ich ein bisschen dran
gebaut da hinten allerdings diese kleine
insel die keine gegen bis hier hält ist
eine kleine insel mit seiner kleinen
buch drin und so richtig richtig geil
ich habe echt nahezu nichts verändert an
der landschaft hier ist wieder am start
viele schreiben mir auch immer economy
man mal wieder so eine typische
minecraft facts welt ja ich weiß die war
schon ganz cool und wird auch immer zu
weihnachten geschmückt und ich denke
auch dass nicht zu weihnachten wieder so
eine fixe welt anstatt erholen werde
auch wenn ich dann neuen computer handy
mal ein zwei wochen habe aber ich weiß
nicht ganz gut weil ich so aussieht
rausfinden jedenfalls schon wenn ich
beispielsweise mal hier drei items
hinschmeißen und ich gehen dass cage ihr
seht da passiert nichts mit diesen items
die liegen hier weiterhin einfach so
komisch rum und wenn ich jetzt
beispielsweise wieder so gehe dann sind
sie gerade wieder haben sich bewegt und
jetzt stoppt wir alles auch dieses
wasser und alles mögliche
das ganze funktioniert allerdings
wirklich mit allen items außer mit
entscheiden items aber ist es außerdem
vollkommen egal ob das jetzt irgendwie
einfach scharf attackiert
genau das jetzt einen schalter bogen mit
beispielsweise flamme 1 ist oder einfach
ein verzaubertes buch mit glück des
meeres drei schmeißt das jetzt einfach
mal hin und das hier hin und ihr seht
schon zack da rechts am rand das glänzt
einfach weiter also es wird quasi
wirklich alles gestoppt außer diese
glenz animation von glänzenden items
ganzes auch bei einem buch der fall wenn
ich jetzt hier mal beispielsweise gibt
es nicht rückwärts laufen sondern
einfach mal ihren buchen schmeiße ihr
seht die animation wennst weiter und das
perfekt nummer zwei
nummer drei habe ich selber raus
gefunden und zwar schaut man beim
spawnen immer in richtung süden
das ist kompletter rechts am randen das
schon wieder so meeres tempel ich weiß
nicht immer so sieht sich entdeckt ist
man meeres tempel am start sind die so
so häufig kommen die so häufig vor ich
dachte die werden so circa sowie
pyramiden in etwa aber ich finde die
einfach immer am laufenden band wenn ich
irgendwie effects welt generiere oder so
jedenfalls ist mir aufgefallen immer
wenn man's pont guckt man in den süden
ich habe das bei fünf welten getestet
und nicht auch mehrmals umgebracht
anschaut in die gleiche richtung
ich gebe es beispielsweise x / kill
eindrücke hier auf wiederbeleben und ihr
seht schon in diese richtung schaue ich
jetzt durch mal f3 und ihr seht der
blauen pfeil zeit genau in die richtung
wo ich am anfang hingucken wenn ich neue
spot bzw getötet wurde
dann schauen wir mal links am rand unter
facing steht jetzt aus wer jetzt
beispielsweise mich mal nach links
drehen steht da ist man nach rechts dann
logischerweise west und hintermänner
logischerweise nord das heißt man schaut
immer in die richtung süden daran kann
man schon mal erkennen dass man
einerseits wenn man es braucht immer in
richtung süden guckt und andererseits
weiß man daran auch das immer dieser
blaue pfeile in richtung süden zeigt das
heißt wenn ich irgendwie überhaupt nicht
weiß wohin oder wenn mein haus irgendwie
in richtung süden ist einfach den blauen
pfeil nach der rote pfeil zeigt immer in
richtung dingsbums in richtung osten und
der grüne halt einfach nach oben ich
weiß nicht was euch dieser fake bringt
aber es ist ein effekt von daher das war
das 5 3
pack nummer vier ist eigentlich auch
recht simpel und zwar hat mir manuell
zugesendet hey luca ich habe ein fact
herausgefunden beziehungsweise ist mir
aufgefallen
die minecraft welt ist nämlich genau
nach dem gleichen prinzip gebaut wie die
menschen sich früher die welt
vorgestellt haben sie ist flach und halt
irgendwo ein ende und sonne und mond
kreisen um sie man hat sich ja damals
vorgestellt okay die erde ist eine
scheibe irgendwann wenn man weiter
siegel feldmann runter jedenfalls ist es
so dass minecraft wirklich eine scheibe
ist das kann man davon ausgehen dass man
wirklich wenn man immer in diese
richtung läuft beispielsweise nie wieder
an diesem punkt irgendwie an gelangen
wird also es ist keine kugel die
irgendwie wo du unendlich mal drum
umfahren kann sondern irgendwann kommt
all diese world order landes quasi
vorbei und wenn man durch die wolke oder
durch kommt fällt man irgendwann einfach
plumps und fällt runter und es ist
wirklich so dass habe ich euch ein paar
folgen vorher schon mal gezeigt hier ist
die sonne
und da hinten kommt gleich der mond zum
vorschein und die kreisen um die erde
wenn ich jetzt ganz nach oben fliege
seht ihr gleich schon
irgendwann den mond da hinten ist
nämlich der mond da geht dann gleich auf
der mond geht jetzt auf die sonne geht
unter das habe ich auch schon mal
gezeigt dass die ganzen sichern
umkreisen um diese platte herum genau
sollen sich die menschen damals das
erden bild vorgestellt und das war feck
nummer vier und jetzt ladet euch endlich
mal diese welt und dabei dieses extrem
cool einmal das an hier ist eine insel
lasten kleiner fluss durch und alles und
blau und war voll cool
der fünfte wurde mir zugesendet von
julius und zwar meint er man kann eine
total verpackte dreier test machen und
zwar brauche ich dafür ganz einfach eine
kiste die ich hier in setzte jetzt keine
kiste hierhin sondern eine kiste hier
und jetzt hat man 12 verschiedenen wenn
ich jetzt bisher einsetzen soll
man möchte seht ihr schon das ganze geht
nicht ich kann mich allerdings hier
zwischen stellen und diesen command
eingeben / set blog leerzeichen welle
leerzeichen welle los face also drei
wellen und dahinter ein leerzeichen und
dann kommt schätzt und dann drücke ich
einfach enter und ihr seht schon jetzt
habe ich hier so was ganz komisches hier
setzt nämlich einen doppel kiste
irgendwie und hier ist allerdings noch
eine kiste wenn ich hier mal reingucken
sehe ich hier okay das ganze kiste wenn
ich hier ein cook habe ich ihnen wie
hier noch sonst lot ich weiß nicht woher
er kommt und dann wenn ich davon weg
gehen bleibt diese kiste auch irgendwie
offen stehen und wenn ich dann hier ein
gucke seht ihr hier ist wieder hier
irgendwie was dann kann ich
beispielsweise eine truhe reinlegen
dann seht ihr hier die truhe ist
natürlich wo ich die reingelegt hab ich
kann jetzt auch ihre einlegen dann sehe
ich nämlich hier die truhe hier die tour
und hier ist einfach keine tour am start
weil das irgendwie wieder hier ist und
hier ist dann irgendwie seine doppel
jazz truhe mit ein bisschen chippen und
alles möglich ich verstehe nicht warum
das ganze irgendwie so ist weil hier
irgendwie noch ein blog ist und die
beiden verbinden sich dann und wann weiß
ich aber das ist auf jeden fall ganz
interessanter effekt und dann kann dich
julius so freunde dieser sechste weg den
ich jetzt einfach mal so dran gehangen
habe wurde mir zugesendet von victor und
zwar schreibt viktor high contrast wenn
man versucht einen mit schnee bedeckten
block mit dem feuerzeug anzuzünden
dann
ok mal ganz kurz zusammengefasst ist es
ein mega cool aussieht mit mega vielen
kleinen inselchen dahinten wenn ihr mal
rechts schaut ist sogar seine coole
stein inseldasein meeres tempel und da
hinten ist auch noch mal im meeres
tempel ja gut hab ich das ist geil dass
ihre moment das ist genau der meeres
tempel die fohlen schon gesehen habe
okay wollte um so es zweimal um die
insel rumgelaufen und einfach zweimal
den gleichen meeres apple gesehen oder
hauptsache erstmal so dass zwei altig
vollidiot jedenfalls ist der effekt ganz
interessant und zwar schreibt er mir
dass man schnee nicht anzünden kann bzw
die flamme dann darüber ist dann schwebt
die flammen an dass das total verbuggt
wenn ich eine birkenholz stufe anziehen
und das anzunehmen ist die flamme
natürlich nicht direkt hier drauf
sondern ein bisschen drüber dann ist
eben abgefackelt wenn ich hellblauen
teppich anzünde sie dir der die die
flamme ist da oben drüber weil sie
natürlich nicht direkt auf dem teppich
sein kann
der teppich ist ein bisschen robuster
dead fackelt mich direkt ab sondern das
feuer breitet sich trotz maus aber das
feuer brennt auf jeden fall wenn ich
allerdings mal schnell erreicht auch
schon so ein kleines kann ich einfach
hier mal gedrückt halten uns nicht dann
eben nicht daneben kann ja auch hier
gedrückt halten und so ich kann da
nichts anzünden dass es total komisch
irgendwie stattdessen breitete sich das
feuer von dem teppich irgendwie immer
weiter aus das ganze geht auch wenn ich
jetzt hier irgendwie mal einen ganzen
block house mache seht ihr geht auch
nicht ich kann schnee nicht anzünden
einfach weil dieses feuer vom schnee
einfach immer direkt gelöscht wie dass
es genauso wie mit dem wasser und das
erklärt sich eigentlich von selbst
allerdings hat mir das victor beendet
und dann kann dich schickt board und
damit würde ich auch schon wieder sagen
war es das für die heutige folge wenn es
euch gefallen hat würde ich mich
definitiv über einen daumen nach oben
freuen und eventuell wenn ihr cool
effect habe diejenigen immer zu senden
würde dann schickte mir doch bitte per
mail an kontraste gmail.com im betreff
einfach cooler minecraft ich bin cool
oder konkret brot und dann sehen wir uns
hoffentlich in irgendeinem nächsten
video wieder